so the question is what can he do i
guess he has to put his rook on the
bottom row and then just
wait it out then the white king can come
around maybe so it
okay what what's this move what is that
mouse slip he's mountain slow slip he
just mouse slipped right gave away his
knight yeah i was a mouse he wanted to
give a check
but he would have reacted more than that
yeah on the camera if that was a mouse
lip did he just think did he just forget
his knight was attacked i think he got a
call from magnus before the game don't
take my writing
whatever you do
but i mean he you could tell he was
really unhappy of his position for the
last 10 15 moves but he didn't realize
a little bit of lack of confidence there
maybe even i mean he didn't realize that
he was holding but he's been shaking his
head for the last 15 moves right even
though he actually defended quite well
yeah and now white is just completely
winning extra night and the key thing is
a set of pawns remain on the board if
both of the pawns disappeared right now
it would actually be a draw rook and
knight against rook is a draw and quite
an easy draw for the for the defending
side but with pawns on the board